foreign
robbing us of one minute of new Ahsoka
it's about preventing another group is
Sabine dreaming about the previously on
this isn't just about finding Ezra ah
Sabine is dreaming about the previously
on did you keep a record of what you
found the turds destroyed it using the
droids ate my homework as an excuse if
it didn't pass muster and Miss
McGillicuddy's math class it's not gonna
work here you can always sign me up for
a good ship Landing but we did not need
nearly every step of their walk up to
this discount Stonehenge I believe we
have located The Reflex point on ctOS
well that seemed really easy kind of
like they just happened to see it out of
the window the spaceship as they flew by
definitely needed a scene about that
putting moth cats in the Willows so you
can cram your lesson about friendship
down our throats at least I'm pretty
sure that's what's going on here
cluttered work area is a sign of talent
cliche
I was hoping you were still here hoping
you'll get the chance to decapitate a
Droid it's a weird thing to get this
excited about is all I'm saying damn so
hard to tell whether Ahsoka is mad sad
or glad the sin is this show not being
about her absolutely dominating the
World Series of Poker take off
arm or
else I mean erotic I mean family
friendly and no way involving droids
being used in a manner other than
instructed fan fiction
[Music]
the head will explode perhaps
between this operation
so locate show will now make this Droid
head inexplicably explodey so the
hospital scene can cosplay as if our
main characters are in danger and Ahsoka
can invoke a non-existent ticking clock
Kara bass that was like three sins for
the price of one but here we do sin
counts not discounts this Droid came
here from corellia the new Republic
Shipyard episode expects me to know what
Corelli is and the new Republic and a
shipyard why does every Star Wars TV
show require so much homework also
getting all that from this wordless
display
should have been dismantled after their
anyone check on that be Behold a foe
more powerful than the Empire bad
project management he doesn't want my
help yes she does is there no part of
Jedi training that focuses on the clear
Communications of thoughts and emotions
screw the force you all need therapy
this place was not built by the Jedi
whose work is it and ancient people from
a distant Galaxy answering a specific
question in the broadest terms possible
also an ancient people from a distant
Galaxy he is very similar to a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away a little
too similar also also I guess it was
only a matter of time before the crammed
Star Wars stories inside other Star Wars
stories I was banking on a deep fried
Obi Skywalk solorion this
is our galaxy what is this a Galaxy for
ants hologram thinking and shooting out
a laser thingy and making the other
hologram thingy do other things
excitement come on
across time
and space Star Wars was becoming a
convoluted mess without forcing with
time and now we're forcing with time
thanks you speak of Dreams vague
fractured hopes and you speak of
dialogue from a vague and fractured
script this is starting to feel a little
too game of thronesy and I don't like
Game of Thrones being mixed in with my
Star Wars I mean by season 8 I didn't
really want Game of Thrones mixed in
with my Game of Thrones what happens
when you find thrawn I hope it's some
cool because they're working hard to
build this guy up like some kind of
space anti-jesus that's going to bring
about starmageddon and if we're being
honest this franchise jumped that shark
a long time ago with its giant space
laser and then that shark jumped another
shark while driving a Corvette Stingray
when they introduced a bigger space
laser so this scene is just a warning to
the series that if you think about
bringing thrawn back with an even bigger
space laser that thing better be big
enough to blow up the whole galaxy so we
can get a hard reset on this and for us
oh such as you've never dreamed as
someone who has recurring dreams about
breakdance fighting a centaur on the
surface of the sun while rocket by
Herbie Hancock plays in the background
round I find this statement to be a bit
presumptuous go to corellia assistant
rock with the final transport I will
stand here and stare at this hinge for a
bit then use the force to summon an Uber
an Empire doesn't just become a republic
overnight
you will still find ex-imperials at
every level of the new republic
government it's kind of wild that this
would be news to Ahsoka and Hera like
the line is here in the show for us and
not them that kind of wild I think she
could use some structure and so could
you so could this show I'm curious what
makes someone ready you just know
so do they Star Wars a nebulous hope I
can't train if Ahsoka doesn't want to
teach me blaming your lack of training
on Ahsoka seems a little unfair you
should blame your lack of training on
Donuts like everyone else does Sabine
that is an excuse and a pool one who
Yang would be the wisest Droid at TV
sins she doesn't want me back she wasn't
even thinking about me if you're gonna
whine like a young Wing then you're
gonna get treated like a youngling so
the sin is younglings I mean kids
over the centuries and I can safely say
your aptitude for the force would fall
short of them all designing a Droid
proficient in megging well then I'm
authorizing it
sure you can
want to bet is this a threat of physical
harm or a threat of staring at him until
he complies one seems illegal and the
other one shouldn't have worked
pre-shoot yelling for the Empire like
the shooting itself would make it super
obvious that you're for the empire
exiting through the window instead of
the door I had a friend in college who
would do this on the regular still to
this day he's an agent of chaos whoever
designed this console without labels
whether it's lightsabers or people with
superpowers it's impossible to
understand how one is more powerful than
the other but someone will win and
someone will lose and no one will care
or have any understanding of why said
winner one and why said loser lost this
Droid is just spinning around a bunch
instead of attacking great job and now
we will all pause with our weapons
interlocked for dramatic effect in a
well-deserved breather these
double-bladed lightsabers should just be
called but wait there's more Sabers this
Droid is littering everywhere
reminds me of the thing about dropping
Pennies from skyscrapers which turns out
to be much less dangerous than dropping
other things and dropping other things
is exactly what Chopper is doing but
it's cool because this Droid is the fun
friend what is that a sequencer hot time
to be working on your tracks morocc you
gotta get those beats in place before
the saber battle doing a risky backflip
that brings your feet closer to the
Flying blade as you rotate instead of
the more logical front flip or just
jumping straight up is every wipe in a
Star Wars a star wipe debate no one will
be seated while Sabine sets down every
single piece of her armor in real time
this haircut we better get moving I'm
sure there's a lot of backstory here and
I get that there's some sort of
symbolism as well however a silk has
been pretty cold towards being this
entire episode to this point you need my
help no you've done enough let's get
going no you need to recover so it
really feels like the main source of
tension between the two was her hairdo
meanwhile on Stargate
stupid rocks think they're so great this
isn't just about finding Ezra
that I for one am very excited to work
with you guys to get into the Octan
Tower find the crackling put this thing
on the thing would you like to see it
well as long as it's not something weird
she quit on me I wish I knew how to quit
you see
she doesn't want me back
she wasn't even thinking about me why
don't you stop whinging and cheer the
up the only time you are wasting
is your own take your sword run me
through she wasn't even thinking about
me
forgot how annoying you are
no caps I'm ready new haircut
same dead arm take us out
number one
[Music]